le festival d'avignon où les enfants ne
sont pas oubliés le centre dramatique
régional d'alsace présente une
adaptation de mowgli le livre de la
jungle
reportage patrick voix et michel est
relevé pour rêver les enfants avignon
n'utilise plus seulement le grand manège
de la place de l'horloge hill park sur
d'autres planètes avec des spectacles
abouti comme boucle voici n'oublie bébé
découvert par lés nous deux tu avais
déjà lu mougli oui quelques y est maudit
et hull a reconnu là oui beaucoup
qu'est ce qui vous a plu oui ça va le
voir et bien c'est du miel les
percussions
le théâtre pour l'enfance et la jeunesse
demande certainement plus d'exigence et
c'est vrai que aussi on s'y perd même
plus d'audace c'est à dire qu'on est
toujours à la recherche de formes +9
plus intéressante il pas par souci
d'originalité mais pour correspondre à
une réelle authenticité jours pour la
première fois moglia titao conseil de la
bourse